sadly las vegas is familiar with mass
shootings the deadliest in american
history happened on the south end of our
most important road
in many ways the valley is still coping
with one october
with lessons for other communities
dealing with these crimes hector mejia
live this afternoon at the downtown
healing garden with that story hector
well the healing garden here has turned
into a sacred place where families
dealing with trauma can
heal and reflect and many in her own
community were left stunned by the
shootings the mass shootings in atlanta
and boulder
mental health experts say reminders of
mass violence can affect people in
different ways
those reminders can also be triggers we
reached out to the vegas strong
resiliency center for coping advice
suggestions include reaching out for
help seeking counseling
as well as trying to stay in your normal
routine as much as possible
i spoke with a one october survivor
randy martens
as she reflected on the lives lost over
the last week in boulder
and atlanta they're taking away
somebody's family member
you know that person could have been the
next president it
they could have been so much to this
world and one selfish person
decided that they weren't worthy enough
we're stronger together than we are
apart
and there are so many helplines there's
so much counseling that is able to be
provided
do it definitely do it
the resiliency center encourages those
affected by the one october tragedy to
reach out for support
the community at large is welcome to
call as well staff are available by
phone
at seven zero two four five five
two four three three phone numbers on
your screen they're available on
weekdays from eight thirty in the
morning to five in the evening
here's another resource bridge
counseling has local therapists
available by phone
24 7 their number also on your screen
and that is 702-474-6450 and local law
enforcement agencies all across the
valley have been
expressing sadness over the shootings
and also sending their condolences
to all of the victims reporting from the
healing garden hector mejia
8 news now